that when a person is ready to say you
know I don't want to be here anymore
oftentimes science has actually shown us
that their brain it's it's considered
stage four cancer
you know everything starts in your mind
right so if my mind's not working right
I'm only out working the sickness
he was clearly like Moses look I'm going
to wipe these people out I'm gonna start
over with you and Moses is like no no
don't don't do that God you know like
turn away from your anger right your
face Wrath
listen emotions have to be felt they
have to do there are indicators of our
thoughts and if we are in a habit of
numbing them and cutting them off then
we won't know what's really going on
inside
[Music]
welcome to today's LED live today is
going to be a sensitive topic and we are
glad that you're here you are not going
to want to miss this because uh I
believe this is a topic that is under
spoken about and yet so many people deal
with this and many people don't even
realize it so we're glad to uh have you
on the show Mia Pyle is an expert in the
area of depression and
um you know people that have wanted to
desire to harm themselves
um this is this is a a topic that I
really feel passionate about especially
as many times as we've spoken to young
people we are hearing this all over and
over and over again so I am very glad to
have you on the show I know you've got a
powerful testimony you're going to share
with us and uh you guys are going to be
in for a treat thank you so much for
having me here I am so excited to be a
part part of the show today to listen I
have really great information just like
you said it's going to be amazing if you
were somebody that has been thinking
about hurting yourself you definitely
want to hear what we have to say today
and if you know someone in your life and
I know that you do that is thinking
about not being here anymore listen
there is hope and you're going to hear
it from someone's lived experience Yours
Truly okay so get your friends call them
text them let them know this is the show
for them today absolutely
so MIA tell us a little bit about like
how you even came into this type of work
um what what dream to you doing this
well you know it's funny I honestly
growing up in Nashville Tennessee I grew
up in a home it was a happy home but
there was a home where there was a lot
of abuse to be honest you know and I
think that resonates with a lot of
people you know where some people you
don't even realize that abuse is taking
place because it just seems normal right
well nevertheless you know going through
school having situations College I
became a missionary I was able to travel
the world you know and that was an
amazing experience coming from a very
poor humble you know circumstances to
now going around the world traveling you
know sharing my humble story as people
would say but I didn't realize that I
unresolved trauma interesting you know I
had been a survivor of actually rape and
even molestation and you know at the
time I didn't really realize the damage
that something like that can do to you
and I remember it wasn't until my sister
was actually abducted and by abduction I
do mean abduction like people literally
they took my sister they raped her left
her for dead on the side of the street
and I remember thinking this doesn't
happen to Everyday People you know there
has to be something wrong with me
there's be something wrong with us there
has to be something wrong with my
community we're cursed right you know
right and I think it also didn't help
growing up okay this is gonna sound very
controversial okay wait just hear me out
in some ways it didn't help being a
Christian I'm gonna say and that's gonna
sound like what how dare you say that
Mia like you can't say that what do you
mean you know believing in God that that
is helpful and it is helpful when your
belief is not toxic yeah but you almost
could come at it like you know I
believed in you God and you didn't
protect me you know it's like you
actually kind of even have these other
experiences where you hear about God's
protection all the time growing up and
all the stories and it's like you didn't
do that to me what's going on yeah
exactly you hit the nail on the head
right there and that was my exact
thought you know like wait a minute you
know why as I'm hearing about God this
hey you you delivered this woman this
person was delivered why not me you know
and also only reading portions of the
Bible and not realizing the whole
picture you know Jesus did say that in
this life we'll have tribulation but be
of good cheer overcome the world and so
I got into this mental health space
after having my own nervous breakdown as
people would call it no not realizing
that that was what was going on you know
I'm a professional I've traveled the
world I'm a missionary doing Bible
studies but all while there's that
unresolved trauma can I ask how old you
were right right um when I was in the
behavioral health hospital or when this
trauma happened how old sure exactly
very tender age so I I honestly believe
that um I was probably experiencing
these situations from the age of three
and then definitely um being raped at
the age of 11. you know and so that's a
really pivotal age because you know
you're thinking about body image and
concept and I remember I'd actually just
become a Christian and so at the church
where I was you know they had been
talking a lot about you know girls they
get married and then they're with their
husbands and your body especially you
saved that for a special time and then
shortly after being assaulted in that
way and thinking to myself oh I'm not
one of God's special girl yeah yeah
and yeah and you kept this to yourself
or did your parents know is this right
absolutely not right and I know for some
people watching the show you know
unfortunately by the statistics it's
your experience yeah and so a lot of
times we don't think anything because
children and then this is important to
know especially for you parents you know
if a child tells you that something has
happened you should believe them let
your let the foundation be belief first
because children don't make up things
like this exactly that I learned this um
watching um ritualistic satanic abuse to
children because the the the
um the officers that had worked a lot
with these children said you know
there's certain things that children
they will not make this up this is not
something that they can even wrap their
mind around that I couldn't even imagine
they don't go there yeah and it's like
if you're hearing a child describe
details absolutely and you need to take
that seriously yes and even the whole
concept itself you know and so I
remember not telling my parents because
I was scared I was gonna get a whooping
right in our body and somehow you think
it's your fault and it's like you know I
caused this or yeah I did something that
you know made this person act like that
or and unfortunately mad at you right
right and unfortunately some sometimes
as parents we actually have that belief
you know like well what did you do where
were you why because it's so
overwhelming that you don't know how to
deal with it right and so you may
actually say the wrong thing thinking
that you're just trying to get to the
bottom of what happened right and couple
that with human nature of like it's not
my fault whose fault is it you know it's
like someone else exactly because Blaine
feels active you know and that's another
reason why
um I believe a lot of people who are
victimized they blame themselves you
know if I can blame someone then at
least somebody can be punished for this
you know especially when people get away
which in the case of my sister you know
they never were brought to Justice we
never found out who those people were
you know no matter what happened they
couldn't find them you know and so
there's this idea of wait something like
this can happen and no one's brought to
justice so then that whole idea of God
and wrestling with whether or not you
can really trust him comes into play WoW
can I ask is your sister okay thank you
for acting bad thank you asking that I'm
so glad you asked that because I
sometimes forget my sister's doing well
okay good yes yes my sister is alive we
got her back home safe and while it was
turmoil watching her heal from the
ordeal and you know it's a journey
healing isn't a in an event it's a
journey right but she's doing well now
she's married she has four kids yes and
so she's she's doing way better than
those lips I think that's an important
part to note just simply that we can't
always control the circumstances but
there can be a positive outcome out of
it and I think that God God has designed
the whole system to heal right you know
and and just just that bit of hope I
hope if there's anybody out there that
has experienced trauma I mean this is
this is walking proof so I'm glad that
we're getting into this well I'm so glad
you brought that up too because that's
what our organization is about the
organization that I found with my
husband paying unwasted the idea that no
matter what we've experienced God is
actually able to heal exceeding and
abundantly above all we could ask or
think we can have healthy relationships
we can't have our right mind no matter
what we've experienced even if for a
time it seems that we're buried under
that mud it's going to take some work
yeah I mean it's not going to be easy
you know in fact sometimes the more
trauma that happens or the younger they
are it's like the more more work that's
going to have to happen to get out of
that but absolutely you know it is
possible and that makes me want to tell
a story actually because now you know as
I said I was a professional I've been
able to travel not realizing this trauma
is there and so when I have my first
child it's a trigger you know and that
can happen to people where man I'm
living my best life and now what
happened you know and so that trigger
will landed me in the behavioral health
hospital you know where I'm in there now
with a blue suit on and I'm walking
around other people who are talking to
themselves and I'm like oh my goodness
I'm a missionary I used to be a
principal of a school okay how is it
that I'm in this place like God is
really really forsaking me now you know
those old mental patterns coming back up
you know of thinking that oh God's
forsaking you look look what's happened
yeah and um this is the story is this
can I just tell you so I remember being
in the behavioral health hospital and I
just like well I can't believe I'm here
and every day you have to be good right
so that in that particular Pace people
can know that you're getting better and
um we would have to sit around and do
tests of not okay we'd have to sit
around and eat and you know show up to
meetings that's how they know you're
getting better well on one particular
day there are these people just sitting
around having testimony time and I'm in
there rubbing my eyes like what
testimony time this is in church you
know what's going on you're giving God
praise and I'll never forget
um there was a veteran there and he said
man I just want to thank God I'm only
hearing one voice today
and that blew me away I don't know about
you all but at that time I knew nothing
about mental health here I have been a
missionary all these years when he said
I've owned I thank God that I'm only
hearing one voice today I'm like
absolutely not that's demon possession
you know like I blew up at him and I'm
like what are you doing you can't be
saying that you know like demon position
what's wrong with you I can't give that
praise wow and then he he says to me he
looks me dead in my eye and he's like
Mia
you will see
I'm like no there is no way see what you
know
that you're crazy and I'm crazy and
we're all God forsaken that's what I'm
gonna see yeah yeah and he's like no
you're gonna see
you are gonna see the goodness of God
Amen and I remember leaving there uh you
know going to my little sale and I got
my little crayon right and I'm writing a
prayer like God you know if you exist
you got to get me out of here you know
and um here I am yay
yes yes yes and so it's been a journey
it has but it's absolutely been worth it
when I look back yeah you know you hear
the story of the Bible like when the
demoniac came after God and and Jesus
when he was walking around you know and
he's cutting himself and he's like
clearly like you know possessed
and then is in his right mind people
can't even believe it and Jesus is just
like go and tell people what what what's
been done for you you know and so I can
imagine like as you were telling that
story I was just thinking of that person
I was like man here's a story in the
Bible of a guy like someone being
completely transformed exactly
immediately and then it's like you know
God didn't be like uh you know oh don't
go tell anybody this or you can't you
can't go in there right no that was go
out and share with other people what
God's done for you you know right I mean
this is totally controversial and I mean
tell me all tell me what you think about
this you know a lot of times as
Christians we believe that because a
person may be having hallucinations
whether it's you know visual or auditory
that oh it's demon possession right
right you know and they don't a lot of
times we don't realize that there
actually could be something else going
on this is not at the negation of demon
possession I mean being a missionary
I've seen people literally foaming at
the mouth and convulsing and we knew
clearly that that was not some other
issue there it was demon possession
um but we've also seen where people are
having these odd behaviors but we
realize that there's something going on
with their brain you know and just to
put it very simply you know like there's
different chemicals for people right
that may not be you know working the way
that they need to maybe from birth maybe
an injury that can actually cause these
situations that's right there's broken
propensities I mean we're a walking
chemistry set right you don't balance
that thing I mean you can you can take
it off kilter real fast so you know I I
don't think it's fair to necessarily say
it's always this but you know I mean
even even Jesus you know when he was
talking about you know healing somebody
I mean he was like you know this is this
is Satan that's causing this yes and the
grand scheme of things but but there's
also physical reasons why thank you for
saying that because it's really
important for parents and people that
are watching this and you're watching
this because you're like oh they're
going to be talking about this today I
needed to hear this and you need to know
that hey God is able you know the story
May something about the story in the
Bible where the disciples are like who
who sinned or whether the Pharisees like
yeah no seeing that this man's born
blind you know and I love how you said
that you know like we're walking
chemistry said you know from the
beginning sin did happen but that
doesn't I'm affected by sin but that
doesn't mean that you know I'm I'm sin
itself the drug and this identity issue
that can cause more illness actually we
don't understand the difference how do
you determine the difference between
demon possession and having chemical
imbalances right right so that's a
really really great question okay and so
I want to kind of share what I've
observed and what I saw in myself I
honestly believe that Satan is an
opportunist okay so I believe that you
can be having physical
um abnormalities and because of those
abnormalities you are now more
vulnerable right just think about it
just something as simple as being hungry
tired right and now you're more likely
to be irritable to be angry to react the
wrong way right Satan is always
suggesting you know what what did she
say to you did he really cut you off in
traffic you know like you're like
Boulevard right you're the void well the
Lord you know but this is like but now
um when we're thinking demon possession
we're thinking complete control Satan
has complete control right think about
the stories and I love the Bible because
many of these psychological Concepts
that we're getting in mental health
they're coming from the Bible and a lot
of people don't realize that but they
really are so here this man the demon
the the demoniac as they say it
um he's cutting himself right and he's
running to Jesus and when he speaks
instead comes out you know we're Legion
and all of that but this man that's
inside he wants to be free you know and
so in this case Satan demon position in
my experience is where Satan has full
control over person and I've allowed it
in some way like I've invited it I've
opened myself to that I've I've answered
a call I've answered a call to action
um that's the best way that I can
explain it based on what I've seen from
in the mission field and even with
people here in the United States or
different places it's like there was a
call and I responded and I decided that
I'm going to do this which is different
from you know I'm learning how to walk
in Christ and I have the Flesh and
sometimes I do the wrong thing I I yield
to a suggestion versus complete full
control of my being yeah I've heard
um you know speaking on the topic of
anime with young kids
um more often than not even in this past
year we would travel around to different
schools and and talk with kids in a wide
range and I have heard this year I can
count on six kids that have come to me
telling me that they hear voices in
their head now that's not enormous
and and always without them even
mentioning anime or anything like this I
asked the question all right as are you
watching anime yes and it's like for
whatever reason having it's like you
voluntarily placed yourself on that
ground so yes you do welcome these
things yeah that incrementally I believe
give the devil more and more ground
until like you said it's fully he's he's
in control absolutely and I believe you
you know whenever we go against
ourselves
we cause harm we cause injury from the
smallest to the largest decision that we
make we cause injury but you know it's
important for people not to be afraid
like oh no I ate too much chocolate cake
male Satan's possessed me no you know
it's it's like no it's a it's an
intentional deliberate believing of God
and I will even say this somebody might
have said well me you're in you're in
Behavioral Health you know you're in the
crazy house you were demon possessed but
and and I was actually in there like
well you guys are praising God who is
God you know who is God that we should
serve him but God understood where I was
he understood that I didn't understand
he understood that my thought patterns
were messed up because I haven't been
sleeping I've become manic right the
chemicals in my brain are causing me to
respond and to think differently but
that is not demon possession I have not
said Satan I want you to have full
control all of me I am answering a call
that you've put out for me to serve you
does that make sense I I'm wondering so
demon possession is like a demon inside
of you but do you believe that in the
process of self-deletion and being
depressed that demons play a role in
that whether suggesting thoughts to you
because I'm thinking of when I was in
high school and I was severely depressed
and I you know wanted to take my own
life right getting out of bed something
as simple as that was literally the
hardest thing to do right it like I
physically felt like there were like
just something was just sitting on me
just all the time like it was just hard
to just get out of bed I didn't want to
eat I didn't and so it's like
I don't and if we know that in the
presence of the Lord there's joy you
know it's like from the opposite end
is it demons trying to get to you trying
to
you know mess around with your life
right I'm so glad that you said that and
brought this in and this is
controversial okay so maybe somebody's
gonna be like uh don't have her back on
her back on this show I want to be
honest and I want to say that I believe
that when a person is ready to say you
know I don't want to be here anymore
oftentimes science has actually shown us
that their brain it's it's considered
level four cancer right or stage four
that's what they would say right this
person has stage four cancer and when
you hear somebody say you have stage
four cancer that means that whatever's
going on in your body has been breaking
down to the point where your your organs
are no longer working your stage four
renal failure you get what I'm saying
like I'll survive or people don't even
work the way that they were made to work
anymore and so whereas one person with a
stage four renal failure you know the
way they use the restroom and their
outcomes of life and how they are doing
life looks totally different from a
person in stage two does that make sense
and so it's almost like the Hope just
giving up is like yeah just let it go
and and and so your brain is going to be
um processing differently when you're in
stage two then when you're in stage four
where stage four is like
you know right now there's really
nothing else we can do for this organ
does that make sense and so when a
person does decide to
um say I'm not going to be here anymore
and complete that
research shows us that their brain in a
sense was in stage four their brain was
no longer working in the way that it
would if you were in stage two or stage
one or even stage three and while we
have had plenty of people recover from
stage four cancer and stage four renal
failure we've had many people die from
failure and stage four depression and
what makes it very controversial is that
okay my kidney just stops working or my
heart just stopped beating or the cancer
in a sense spreads and takes over my
organ whereas with the person who ends
their life
um now you're like well you you actually
did something to do that you know but
it's because of you know everything
starts in your mind right so if my
mind's not working right I'm only out
working the sickness and so it's really
something to think about and that's why
often I say
you know and you know maybe I won't come
if you need to come back but I'm just
gonna say it no I believe that people
who are watching this show today
um there are some of you out here you
have lost loved ones to Suicide you know
I've lost loved ones to Suicide I was
suicidal you said you were suicidal as
well Brittany you know and I just want
you to know that
it will not be helpful to think of that
person as oh man they just gave
themselves over to Satan and Satan took
their lives and I'm not saying that for
some people it is a situation where I
have given myself over to say and he has
full complete control and now I end my
life I'm not saying that does not happen
but more often than not consider the
idea that the person who has died by
Suicide has done so because they're they
were at stage four and their brain was
no longer working in the proper way
so how do you
um
I guess so a common Christian belief is
that self-deletion is in I guess
unforgivable sin and I really will not
be in heaven and that's something that I
think is kind of a group thing among
Christians how would you respond to that
if someone were to say that right and I
actually have had to work with families
who have lost loved ones to suicide in
the work that I do and I'm gonna you
know once again very controversial uh
thought
um Samson he said God and let me go when
I do this thing let me go you know and
later in Hebrews we read that Samson's
in the faith Hall of Fame right you know
and and and that's self-deletion you
know right um God didn't have to allow
the bricks to kill him we know God could
have supernaturally preserved
um Samson's life we know there are
people who have actually taken the means
to take their life and they've been
supernaturally spared you know even
though they pulled the trigger you know
or they took the pills or whatever the
case may be and so um I really think
that as Christians the biggest thing
that we should be speaking more than oh
that's this is the outcome this is the
Judgment I don't think that's our place
I I believe firmly that our place is
actually to be a source of comfort a
source of Hope and that if I have lost
someone to Suicide that I comfort myself
in the Lord and I don't see God as The
Punisher of you know these acts because
I really don't know you know what I mean
and so when I get to heaven I will know
what what is dark will be made light you
know and I believe that Christ always
gives us hope you know I feel like the
enemy is the one that takes hope
completely away and and what's beautiful
as is we know that God is known as the
righteous judge so so I believe he takes
these things into account I'm sorry I I
know this may offend some people yes but
a little girl that got abused at age
three and had a traumatic life and ended
up ending her life she didn't choose
that at three years old that's not her
fault yes and God has to take that into
account the whole life as a whole and at
the end of the day we will all say God
you made the right choice I don't think
it's fair and I tell people that all the
time I don't think it's fair we can't
make that judgment call I'll make it I
think we we see that with Mary Magdalene
too how they were trying to judge her on
that one account one you know if Jesus
had to remind everyone you know cast the
first stone if you haven't sinned you
know and he's taken to account what
could have what happened in her life to
lead her to that like no one would just
want to just do that right you know it
was a very rare right and it's a very
taxing thing to be going through so yeah
that's a good point and and I think like
you're bringing up an excellent point
with anything not just somebody who
wants to end their life but but we as a
Christian are we as so a source of Hope
and help to other people are we
encouraging or we deal with this online
all the time there are people who love
to get on and just slam you you're not
doing this right discouragement through
and through and it's like we're so quick
to attack each other when invest in what
I read in the Bible God isn't very you
know helpful
and consider that if I'm a person who is
constantly finding fault and constantly
attacking others it's possible that
they're and this is going to sound scary
for somebody but contribute that you
yourself may actually be battling with a
mental illness or when I say Mental
Illness but a mental issue so we know
that you know there's a Continuum when
we think about mental health you know
and so someone who decides to
self-delete is somewhat with Sayers
decide they don't want to be here it's
at the end of that Continuum but all
along the way there are places where our
mental uh um Health our our ability to
process and reason things needs to be
healed you know and so we consider that
man the person that has been harmed from
three years old there are chemical
things that have happened to that
person's brain there are things that
have happened to that person's body and
unless they receive the medicine whether
it's psychological or you know an actual
medication
um they are going to get sick and die
does that make sense um and how many
Christians actually have the tools or
know that they have the tools to say hey
if my child came to me and said
someone's been hurting them or
something's been going on you have the
tools to actually walk them through
their anger walk them through their
depression walk them through their
anxiety so many people don't have the
tools they think that oh if I just pray
about it it will go away if I just have
enough faith and then when that's not
working because maybe your loved one has
actually developed a a serious condition
such as bipolar bipolar schizophrenia
which is not just pray it away there are
medical interventions that actually need
to happen to help that person preserve
the quality of their life then what do
you do and that's why where my work
comes in because being able to spread
awareness and to say you know mental
illness mental illness is an illness
just like any other illness and there
can be something done for cancer there
can be something done for your
depression for schizophrenia something
can be done
so so I I knew were were probably going
to get into the nuts and bolts of this
um because we're going to do a couple of
episodes on this and I and I don't want
to like take too much time in the
mechanics of it because I want to hear
your testimony if you have some more
things to share about that
um but what if you talk about it is it
simply just just bringing awareness in
your own mind is that what begins the
healing process
um I mean how would you begin to
approach that as someone has been
traumatized early on what are some of
the steps that they need to to sort of
begin to take or so that the family
members or somebody that's a co-worker
or a friend or how do we how do we begin
to start the healing process that's
excellent that's such an excellent
question so first I want to talk to the
person who you know you have you you can
tell that you're not yourself and you're
struggling you're battling maybe you
haven't you know experienced you know
assault or any of those things you may
just feel like my lifestyle drugs you
know it's mediocre you know nothing bad
has happened to me that you can tell but
you just are like you know I don't want
to be here so the first thing we want to
do is we want to find someone we can
trust and when I say trust absolutely
trust you know that person the one that
is gonna laugh with you they're gonna
uphold you they're going to encourage
you they do not judge you for what you
do and say right that person that you
can trust right and if you don't feel
that you have someone like that another
good place is to start with a therapist
or a counselor or a trained clergy
person that can be a source of trust to
you right and so that's where I love to
start this another place that you want
to start is actually with your primary
care physician now some people they do
not have a primary care physician so you
may consider going to a clinic where
there are people that are there so that
you can say you know what um I'm I've
been experiencing these feelings I I
feel this way and I just want to come
here for help a lot of times people are
having a depressed mood or a sad outcome
so it feels but they're actually low in
vitamin D3 right which can make a huge
difference you know or there may be some
other underlying medical condition and
so your primary care physician will be
able to assess and say okay this is what
we believe is going on let's run some
more tests you know actually as much as
people are diagnosed with depression
technically you know it's science right
so science is experiment and trial and
era and so um that's good to know so
those are two big things you know who
can I trust who can I talk to about to
begin my journey and then Senior primary
care physician is going to make a big
difference yeah I want to say have you
read the book this is a side note have
you read the book on the body keeps the
score by best um vessel vandercool I
love that book I love that book yeah he
emphasizes how important Community is
when it comes to dealing with any type
of mental illness especially depression
and when I think back to that time in my
life like I really had to go through it
alone known for a majority of the time I
I thank you for you know even being
willing to be on the show and vulnerable
it's a difficult thing to do and even
you know this is this is why it's
important for us to have this
conversations I I do feel yeah that as a
co-worker you know it's like I've had
co-workers that have dealt with this and
it's like how do you deal with it
absolutely and you know what I love is
that man we can we can cry you know it's
okay to take off the mask and it's okay
to break down honestly and you know
maybe it's getting old but I'm gonna say
it anyway it's okay to not be okay you
know and it is hard to have to say that
you know some of the people that have
been toxic for me are family or or I've
been toxic to myself you know and that's
one of the things I learned at the
behavioral health hospital like when I
was there man that was my community
because I honestly felt like my
Christian friends and I hate to say it
I'm not gonna say denomination but my
friends
um I just felt like nobody was gonna get
it and nobody's gonna understand there's
gonna be these toxic positivity and I
also felt like I was cast in a role you
know what I mean like we're talking
about TV and stuff so I'm casting this
role of the the strong one you know the
one who's got it all together that has
the answers you know unshakable Faith
person so it's hard to step out of the
role you know but in the behavioral
health hospital it was just so wonderful
because nobody had on their mask you
know there are people over NASA there
there were people who were running these
Fortune 500 countries I mean um
companies there you know and then there
were people who talk to themselves on
the street yeah and people were everyday
people like myself and we were just all
there needing help and I'm not trying to
say everybody needs to go to behavioral
health but if you feel like you don't
want to be here anymore and it's getting
really bad for you it's not a black a
bad place to stop you know and to be
able to get your bearings and maybe find
a community that you wouldn't have known
was there that can be helpful yeah it's
just recognizing that you might have an
issue and in Having the courage to say I
need to seek out and either tell
somebody or find somebody that I can
begin this process of healing for I
think just keeping it internalized into
yourself is just a festering issue that
will break your organs down from the
inside yes that's part of the problem
and can I say this you know especially
for leaders I think a lot of times
leaders are at risk a lot of times
leaders have unhealthy habits and what
do we do we we toxify our our families
because we don't know how to deal with
the anger we don't know how to deal with
the pressure we we may be in a role you
know I feel like we have to keep that
role and we don't know what to do with
it you know and so we're we're can I
just go there and say we're farting
we're farting on people you know we're
farting on ourselves we're making the
atmosphere unhealthy you know they are
toxic because we don't know how to deal
with our gas to give that analogy you
know and there are simple things that we
can do that are practical that are
faith-based right that can help us deal
with the gas so that we can get better
and not get worse yeah I I think the one
thing that I think we should acknowledge
too is
um like we know that Community is
important but when you're a child like
you can't just
if you don't know what to do yeah you
don't know like you need to go you need
to be able to have someone to go to them
and say I need help can you pay for a
therapist and what if they can't afford
a therapist because I know for me like
when I went to school my counselor was
not the best like what they told me was
the reason why you're feeling like this
is because you need to find yourself
and when I walked out I never went back
in wow you know and then like I have a
mom who's a single mother of two kids
she's trying to you know she has her own
problems that she's dealing with right
you know and she doesn't have a lot of
help and then you know I also had
another family who said another family
member who said to me like and they
didn't know I was this depressed but
because their mindset was already like
this I knew I couldn't go to them right
and so they would say things like you
know people who you know kill themselves
like they're just weak and you know like
and they would tell me like oh all you
have to do is go to school like you
don't have any you have bills to pay
like what are you depressed for and so
when you have these like you know it
says where do you go where do you go and
when you don't have friends what do you
do so so you kind of that's good there's
kind of two things that that we're
dealing with here it's like from your
perspective uh or from a young child's
perspective that's feeling those
feelings and then doesn't feel the
support around them what do you do but
then also as a parent the interesting
thing to me is like
the parent didn't know well well how how
how can you speak to parents that maybe
can check in make sure so that we're not
like you know hey I didn't know I'm
sorry that you were feeling like this
it's like what are some of the steps
that that
um we can speak to the adults or the
parents and and you know how do you even
check in with your kid make sure they're
not right thanks pretty much thank you
for asking that this is so this is so
good so I first want to talk to that
child you know that child that feels
like you know
you know you sense that well I can't
talk to Mom can't talk to Dad or can't
talk to these people
but I want to encourage you there is
someone there is someone you may not see
it now you may not realize it but there
God always gives us support and and and
and it's not just God himself you know
some people are like well God is my
support no
God will reveal to you
who you can talk to who you can trust he
will show you and even if you think
about it for you know everyone's been
depressed first of all that's another
thing so depression let's destigmatized
that everyone's been depressed doesn't
matter who you are right principal
Pastor teacher mother father everyone
has been depressed people have thought
about taking their their lives it's it's
common it's not something that's new and
so to that child really
um don't give up you know if there's the
if it you know if at first you don't
succeed do try and try again know that
you will find somebody that person can
find you there is support there is
support somewhere something that I love
when I couldn't find that supporter I
didn't really feel like I saw it
um I would do something and it's going
to sound very simple but it really does
work I would literally draw
and I would write because that's what
was helpful for me you know and I didn't
feel like you know the physical person
was there and I definitely didn't want
to pray about anything that I would
write and I would draw and I would
create these narratives and this is
another show that'll be coming up but a
lot of times that's why we are diving
into these shows so that we can escape
but a really healthy way to do it is
actually to be able to journal you know
break out your crayons okay and adults
we we can do this too you know break out
your crayons you know what I'm saying
and you can draw and you can write you
can color and no one has to see it you
know if you feel you know ashamed of
whatever comes out on paper you can
always destroy it it's okay you know
it's yours you know so this is another
outlet that you can have but there is
support there's an adult there there's
maybe an older you young person that you
can begin to talk to you know and and
just keep your eye out for that person
who is that person that that um that
makes you feel comfortable and safe and
they may not be right around you but
they're somewhere just kind of keep your
mind for that so now for parents
parents men are super super we we feel
this super pressure and super
um like you know there's so much going
on for parents that we can really miss
it you know what I'm saying because we
are answering the call of so many things
especially now after you know the
pandemic if you can say after and so a
huge thing that I want to say for
parents is number one be aware of your
own Mental Health
like stop feeling like you have to have
it all together in front of your kids
you know it's okay for them to see you
cry it is okay for them to see you break
down it is because it's teaching them
emotional maturity to know that it's
actually immature to think that I'm
supposed to always be positive and happy
and you know all is well you know like
it's okay if your parent if your kids
see you break down
tears are cathartic you know so I it's
going to be hard for me to help my child
if I'm so um choked by my own
um pain and pressure and so as a parent
watching this
how can you get the help that you need
so that you can be more present but then
also being able to have a conversation
with your kids like you know I saw this
show today and this is what they were
talking about and I honestly want to ask
you you know how are you doing
and I'm not gonna when I ask the
question as a parent how are you doing
I'm listening I'm gonna end these and
this goes into
um I want to pull up a slide for you
okay because parents they need to see
this this is called algae this is coming
from the mental health first aid
protocol all right and it's a wonderful
protocol because it helps you help the
people right around you kids you can do
this with your peers and adults we can
do this with each other and with our
kids and so number one you know you're
assessing for risk of suicide or harm
but what you're doing is you can simply
start off with you know
how are you today you know how how are
you doing and when you ask the question
you wait to hear what they have to say
and please don't give any advice right
now you know don't give any suggestion
no matter what comes out of their mouth
no matter what comes out of their
judgmental free zone absolutely which
leads to number two listen without
judgment or they say listen
non-judgmentally which is can be really
hard you know because if your child
tells you that hey mom I've actually
been cutting myself yeah you know what
he you know like big gasp but at this
point we need to be like the duck on the
pond but when you see that duck they're
smooth but their feet might be just
Patty patting away like oh my goodness
my child's telling me they're cutting
themselves I want to explode but we need
to listen without judgment you know and
we need to ask those questions okay
um what's making you feel that you need
to do this why are you doing this and
then giving reassurance okay
giving reassurance would sound like this
you know man I'm just so glad you told
me thank you
I'm just so glad that we're having this
conversation and we can have this moment
right now because you may get a sliver
of the information there but you may
have that opportunity open the door for
a safe space to share more down the road
exactly you never want to close the door
and closing the door would sound like
what why are you doing that that's so
irresponsible what if people find out
you know what did I do wrong that you're
doing this you know that's judgment and
that's like closing the door you know
but then definitely you want to
encourage appropriate professional help
as you're listening to that child
listening to that co-worker you know
giving them that opportunity to unburden
themselves you can still cycle back and
say you know based on what you're
telling me and based on what you hear
you know if it sounds really bad like
you know I've just stopped taking a bath
and you hear words like I just don't
want to be here anymore or you know I
just wish I didn't have to wake up again
then you want to ask the question you
know are you thinking about killing
yourself
are you thinking about dying by Suicide
right and notice I said Dying by versus
committed whole another show but are you
thinking about killing yourself and
people think that if you ask the
question you're putting it on their mind
like you're gonna make them want to do
it but nine times out of ten if they
were thinking it's already on their mind
and you'd rather hear them say no I'd
never do that then well actually you
know yeah or they might say no I'm not
going to kill myself I just you know I
don't want to wake up anymore where
they're kind of still saying yes
you know what I mean be aware of that
sign absolutely and so this is where now
we start to take them through you know
well if you did it if you if you didn't
want to be here anymore have you
actually thought about what you would do
and that can be really scary you know
that duck on the pond have you thought
about what you would do and the reason
you're asking this is because in your
assessment you're trying to find out how
serious how imminent is this person
about their decision you know about like
where are they on this spectrum of you
know what stage are they we talked about
stages right and so have you thought
about what you would do have you thought
about when you would do this you know
and if the person is giving you answers
to those questions like man you know no
I haven't thought about it I just
thought I'd take some pills notice there
was a no but a yes right A lot of times
we talk like that I haven't you know and
man you know just maybe by my birthday I
won't be here you see what I'm saying
that's like a date you know so it's like
they're letting you know hey this is
this is getting serious we're we're
going up the Spectrum here you know
um and so this is where we now want to
use resources that are available to us
because you know we may not feel
equipped to get them from this hot
moment that we don't realize is
happening to a cool moment and so what I
like to do you know as a mental first
aid instructor is be able to say okay
I'm so glad you know that you're telling
me this I can see this is hurting you I
can see that you're really distressed
and you know I want us to do something
about it you know can we do something
about this you know this is what I saw
on little light they said there's a
number that we can call and I want to
share that with you and I'll go back to
this slide after but these are some
resources that you can actually use you
know
um 988 is the newest number they used to
have another 1 800 number but now if you
dial or text 988 you can actually get an
operator that can help you and for those
people who might be like oh no when I
call they're going to take me off to
jail or to the behavioral health no they
are trying to take you from a hot moment
to a cool moment now I will say and I
want to be honest so that you can be
prepared that sometimes you know just
like people show up to work and they
won't want to be there
there's a chance that you could call and
an operator is not the best but remember
if at first we don't succeed we're going
to try again okay we're gonna call back
and get a different operator right we're
gonna call again and get a different
operator all right we're gonna if we're
not gonna call we're gonna text and
texting is really great because as a
young person if you don't want your
parents or somebody to hear you saying
you know I'm really suicidal you know
then being able to text that person will
text you back and they can talk to you
give you resources and kind of guide you
I personally have used the hotlines and
been able to go back you know go on with
my day
and not wind up in the hospital because
I use the number you see and that's even
after being out of Behavioral Health
because healing is an onion you know and
listen there are people who are watching
this and you're like you know I'm not
suicidal you know I'm not thinking about
no longer being here but I'm really
struggling and I honestly don't feel
like there's anyone around me that I can
talk to then you have warm lines every
state has a warm line or a warm line
connected and so you can Google what are
the warm lines in my area and they
should be able to connect you to the
appropriate resources free resources or
even resources that you can use to pay
um for parents who are like you know I
can tell that my child is just different
I don't know they won't talk to me but I
know something's going on we can you
know talk to our child about okay
there's a resource Psychology today
because in some of our circles we don't
feel comfortable to talk to the pastor
even the therapeutic resources that are
there we're concerned that it's going to
get back in the church or it's going to
get to somebody so we can use Psychology
today to come completely out of our
Circle and find help okay and then
obviously for those who may struggle
with their finances there are free
counseling resources and so that's
something that you can Google and even
as a child you know we're talking about
children who may be wondering well
children are so adapt now you know you
can you can actually use these same
resources yourself if you're a child and
you're watching the show and you're
listening you know you can actually use
these resources too to see how you can
connect okay to someone that can help
you
I have a question because you said that
so eloquently and beautifully but I'll
tell you what I don't know if I'd be the
little duck with the little feet
underneath the water like this I'd be
like panicking it can you show emotion
as a parent if my child tells me that
they would like to end their life I
don't know how I'd keep the tears in
right and and I want to say you know not
asking any parent to not be human but
what we're asking is that you try to be
as calm as possible because often you
know you've opened this conversation you
you've taken the the love in your heart
and the peace to open the door so if
you've opened the door the and you need
to open the door right if you're seeing
things you need to open the door but if
you feel one that you're not going to be
the right person maybe the relationship
you have with that child is already
strained and you know you're not the one
because you're gonna pop off then you
can enlist a friend a uncle a teacher
that you know that child has respect for
that you know that child is good with
and say listen this is what I'm seeing
I'm not the person I feel like if they
say something to me I'm not going to
respond well I need you to do this I
need you to do this assessment that
they're they shared with me okay ask
them how they're doing ask them are they
thinking about dying by Suicide can you
do this for me because I'm not the
person for IT yeah is it appropriate for
teachers to be that person
um sort of like you know at what level
is it like you're overstepping the
bounds of that person's family or you
know because I know a lot of teachers
watch our show right what did you say to
them absolutely you know if we're seeing
signs and symptoms that things are not
quite right for our students or for our
co-workers which is totally possible you
know and I want to say this too don't
believe that just because a person is
like good morning hi good work happy
Sabbath happy Sunday whatever the case
may be that that means that they're
actually be happy in fact I remember
being extremely happy just before I was
going to take my life highs and lows
exactly because I had resolved that okay
I know how I'm gonna end this I know
that you know very soon I'm not gonna
have to be here anymore and I became
very happy actually in fact that's one
of the Key signs for people just before
they die by Suicide a lot of people
report that hey all of a sudden they
were just so happy and cheerful and then
next thing you know I hear that they
died what's going on it's because
they've realized like okay I know how
I'm gonna end this and I'm relieved you
know and so don't take for granted that
the person who was suicidal may have a
big smile on their face they may seem
like the caretaker looking out for
everybody is everybody okay that person
may actually be experiencing some toxic
positivity you know or they they may be
in that role again and so we really want
to
um you know just make it a habit of hey
you know I just want to know how you're
doing have real conversation here are
some key times teachers pastors people
has the person experience loss on some
level and this is a key indicator
because who hasn't experience loss after
these past two to three years so there
we go there goes one
um what um have they experienced
traumatic and a traumatic event which
can also be like a loss right
um have they have they not been showing
up to things like they usually do or are
they hyper showing up in the sense that
you know I'm sick but I should be at
home you know I'm I'm showing signs that
I'm not actually taking time to take
care of myself does that make sense and
these are some things that can let us
know and of course you know looking
unkept you know or smells or looking
overly kept you know there's just
different things that we can kind of
like it's just different you know what
what's different that's not a normal big
Handler for this person exactly exactly
yeah I like that you've laid out that if
the parent recognizes that they're not
the one to have that conversation then
they can go to a friend
um but it I think for a
I guess we're emotional availability was
never instilled in the home like I think
sometimes it's easier to ask a younger
child how are you doing yep but when
you've passed those first five years of
childhood where you're supposed to be
bonding with your mother or father and
then you go into you know like your
early adolescent years and then you go
into like oh no now you're 15 and you
just have been taught
like we don't show emotions in this
house we don't talk about our problems
it's either the child is going to
pretend like they're okay or if the
parent does come and ask like for me I
just said I'm fine right because I
didn't think that I could actually be
vulnerable about that so
with that too that would mean that no
one knows so how can a parent I guess
like how do you guide that situation at
that point you mean like if if if the
parent asks on the child no no
everything's fine right so it's like
yeah what do you do if
because it's one thing if you were if
your child is willing to talk to you
right and you're and you're willing to
say okay I'm not the best person for
this letter I redirect but if there's
already been this thing where there's no
trust yeah how how do you because that
would take a huge level of awareness for
a parent to recognize that right and if
a parent already doesn't have the
emotional
um I guess responsibility or capacity
because of their own childhood traumas
right how do you do like you know it's
just it really just leaves the child
very isolated right I hear what you're
saying and so this is so there's two
things that I'm hearing as I listen to
you and there's one this is how I'm
thinking about it as I'm listening to
you let me know if I'm I'm on track with
your question
one is that hey I'm a parent and there's
this issue in our family and we kind of
in this house have a culture that we
don't share our emotions however I do
see that my child is struggling things
are not quite right for them they're
different they're not showing up the way
they usually do in the home
yet we don't have a relationship and so
what am I going to do because I know we
don't have a relationship and I know we
have a certain culture well the tendency
for a lot of parents is just to be like
you know get it together right like um
you know you need to do more things or
you need to get out here but you're
watching the show and you're hearing
that something different actually needs
to happen once again if you know that
the relationship is strained you can
enlist
you know who your child connects to that
is a person a positive source for them
and if you don't know this is an
indication that the family is in need of
Greater help you know what I mean like
if as you're listening to this and
you're like wow I actually don't know
who I would enlist to help my child then
this is an indication of the disconnect
that is happening in your home and for
that you're definitely gonna wanna tap
into resources that can help you bridge
that Gap like therapists counselors
mental health coaches and
you know because there's so much stigma
with mental health it may be good to say
you know what we're going to get a coach
just like I'm going to get a coach for
um you know Sports I'm going to get a
coach for our our families will be how
about that now that's that's incredible
because that's for the parent that's
going to do something like that it's
really hard to say when the parent isn't
of that mindset so if you are a child
that's in that situation and you're
hearing this you have incredible power
and ability to tap into the resources
that we've been sharing you don't have
to feel that you have to be dependent on
your family your family circumstances in
order to get the help that you need you
have resources now that you can use to
find the help that you need for yourself
outside of the circle whether it be your
church your home within your job
description you being a coach or do you
coach people like this well absolutely
um more so for us now we kind of coached
High performing professionals and we
also so coach entrepreneurs but we
definitely do like classes and seminars
where we come into a church or a
business and our job is to actually
destigmatize mental health one by
sharing the fact that we all have it
right we all have we're all on the
Spectrum as it were
um in terms of our mental health so we
definitely do that we open up the
conversation because sometimes like you
said Brittany how do we even get this
conversation started you know can I just
throw something in there too please come
on Jesus was a Man of Sorrows
so that's often not brought up we think
of Jesus as this like you know he's just
this loving ready to wrap his arms
around but he cried I mean I mean the
the idea that Jesus was even walking up
to the situation with Lazarus and
recognizing what everybody's feeling
Jesus knows he's going to raise him from
the dead in fact that's why he said this
has happened so that the son of man can
be glorified right but Jesus feels The
Compassion of everybody around and
breaks down okay I love that you brought
in Jesus because one of the things that
really healed me was the idea that Jesus
said my God my God my God my God why
have you forsaken me why have you
forsaken me you know and we always say
in church you know Jesus spelled sin and
he was but here Jesus is emoting as we
say you know what I'm saying he is
sharing his deep true emotions it's not
hidden his disciples are there his
mother is there the religious people are
there God himself is there and he's
talking and he's saying it loud enough
for it to be recorded in the Bible that
he feels forsaken by God and he's saying
something about it and when I learned
that I could do that even to God himself
and say God you have forsaken me I feel
that you forsaken me and to realize I'm
not gonna get struck down by God he's
not gonna punish me he's not gonna make
my life worse but you know because of
how I feel and that's a key point for
parents too Jesus is teaching us just
you know God was there with Jesus on the
cross you know he was there but he felt
that he wasn't there you know um and you
know different people deal uh you know
they I'm not a theologian so I'm not
trying to you know insert a belief but
God I say he never leaves nor forsakes
us yeah so either he's telling the truth
or he's not that's right now and he
doesn't lie yeah so what is telling the
truth
I just wanted to highlight these last
two okay because this is really
important I I want to really highlight
the encouraging appropriate professional
help so that's once again that parent
who may feel like you know I'm not the
one and I can't even think of who would
be the one primary care physician is
awesome you know that's a good place to
start okay
um and if you feel you know we're people
where we don't have to be stuck to one
primary care physician we can get a
second opinion and so that's a really
good place to start but also remembering
and encouraging
um self-help strategies sales help
strategies actually work and what are
they things like getting outside like
going for a walk being able to read a
really good book like Brittany and I we
were talking about a book that we're
reading and it is amazing it is so
helpful and you don't hear the words
mental health in there but she's totally
talking about mental health so finding a
really good book that speaks to your
spirit and not feeling like the only
book I can read to help myself this
controversial is the Bible I mean I must
just only read the Bible and memorize
this many bible promises and then I'll
be okay like God has so just like he has
so many different trees varieties of
things that heal our bodies their leaves
are for the healing of the nation he has
so many different ways he can heal us
through different means okay being able
to form support groups which is
something I'm really passionate about
like I personally believe every college
should create a support group not just
from the counseling services but where
students are trained and empowered to be
able to create support groups within
their dorm or within their you know
their studies to be able to come
together and say hey this is what's
going on with us and how do we feel
about it be able to talk and know that
they can end on positive right another
one that's really huge gratefulness
and you know when people used to tell me
like you know you know be thankful I'd
be like for what you know right I'm
tired and very bad you know I don't I
don't I don't see anything to be
grateful for you know what I mean but it
actually scientifically it really helps
your brain yeah so there's so much
research has been done you know on on
the power of gratitude and gratefulness
and even Jesus says that you know don't
go to sleep on your raft but actually
this is a self-help strategy you know
thinking of what are five things I can
be grateful for even if they're really
small I'm glad I ate today I'm glad this
day's over you know I I'm glad I had
pizza you know whatever the case may be
but just being grateful is another way
that actually starts to change some of
the chemicals this is the last thing I
want to say because I know you know time
is going but don't be afraid to get help
okay like don't be afraid to go to the
medical community for help
whether it's a therapist some things
just can't be diyed you know they can't
be do it yourself you need help because
sometimes we don't know how to
objectively look at our own minds and
thoughts and to see that we're believing
lies about ourselves and about God and
so that's going to be really big this
has been absolutely amazing and I know
that we could probably keep going for
hours and hours and I thank you okay one
more minute I just say something you
have something okay really quick uh when
I just want to backtrack to when you
were talking about
um getting a family coach now just in
case there is a thought in someone's
mind saying I don't have money to afford
that are there free resources right
absolutely absolutely so
um when you Google and you look for
resources for counseling and BRP there
are always free resources out there
there absolutely are soap times and this
is for someone you know we need to
create the resource ourselves like if I
am struggling you know what I'm about to
start a group of people we're gonna get
together we're gonna start there okay
and so this is just the idea to put out
there but of course this is not for more
serious issues like you know I'm hearing
voices I'm having hallucinations I
really do feel like I want to die then
obviously starting your own group is not
even going to happen right and so not in
those cases but for some of us you know
just being able to create Community will
be really helpful but there are free
resources out there for those who are
wondering absolutely cool and and like
you mentioned um you know if there's
somebody like in a school setting
try and start a conversation like you
said start a group that that can begin
these conversations I think word places
more businesses more families more
church members need to have this
conversation absolutely absolutely and
I'm glad you said that and I'm so glad
we're talking about this because I want
you to know that Mental Health First Aid
is actually a resource that is huge okay
and and that's what we do but there is
not just me it's the actual organization
Mental Health First Aid where you as a
everyday person everyday professional
can learn how to recognize the signs and
symptoms of mental illness and how to
respond appropriately and that can
actually be a free resource for people
to be able to know what to do know how
to point them to help if the person says
that they want to kill themselves you've
heard what I've said but you need more
practice than as a pastor even
counselors take this course so they can
freshen up and create a language that we
all speak right that is um really
helpful and so Mental Health First Aid
um we've created our own Pro program
that we love because it's called M hero
where we're able to weave in you know
biblical principles and things of that
nature and kind of also give people
practical tips and tools to help
increase their own mental acuity and
wellness as it is and so those are
things that you can check into for
yourself but there's programs out there
so I'll put the links of the
descriptions
um in the description below here so
um you can share with us some of those
links and we'll provide those for you
sure as a Believer I know we're talking
about all those you know techniques and
easy bolting all stuff that you were
sharing testimony yeah and to me is that
I just want to share with us and that
moment of darkness and that moment of
guilt or what you went through and
everything
please share with us in that moment
whether you said you know what I want
you God in my life right maybe you
didn't know like you know maybe you read
some promises and all this stuff because
that's different like you know yeah
God's gonna be there for you but I was
like what about in my personal life like
were you the faith right like I'm gonna
just let it go and say God please come
to my life right and uh please share
with us your personal walk to end this
your testimony right and and that's
really good and this is gonna sound bad
okay guys don't judge me all right to be
honest with you I I didn't say God I
want you in my life I said with my
little crayon God if you're real you've
got to get me out of this crazy house
right and I lifted that and I remember
actually continuing to be angry with God
and to be an antagonist as a Christian
two people that were trying to tell me
about God and bible promises and it was
actually God that took that little
crayon prayer and he pursued me and he's
in he's sitting resources and that's
what I'm saying he sent resources to me
you know that I could that I could hear
the message from you know because some
people they were too I'm gonna say it
too churchy and to Bible and and there's
no such thing but that's how I felt and
so if they had come to me sharing bible
promises or you know God loves you it
would have caused like agitation in my
spirit because I was just so angry you
know but um
what made me surrender was the
persistent love you know the persistent
love and actually having those lies
about God cleared up you know the lie
that I have to be happy all the time the
lie that I have to be perfect all the
time you know the lie that God's just
watching to see you know did you get it
right today nope well I don't know you
know judgment's coming you know just
being able to unburden myself from a lot
of those things really created space in
my heart for a love and desire for God
and um being able to I I would even say
and I want to be honest I don't want to
sound like I'm sitting up here never
been depressed again never you know
struggled with my faith again there are
times where I still find myself like my
God my God why have you forsaken me you
know like and I'll feel shame for being
back in that place but then I'll
remember why well he got me out of there
you know he can he can do it again and
so I could say that's how the testimony
is going you know and that's how it able
in is that God will be Victor in my life
you know and he will be the one that
gets me all the way to heaven despite
all that needs to be done in my heart
amen you know I think it's important to
recognize too
um emotions like God had Fierce anger
you know you think about it more like
okay likes you think when you get angry
and Cody's angry that that there's
something sinful about that all right
good God that's not sin no and he I mean
he was clearly like Moses look I'm going
to wipe these people out I'm gonna start
over with you and Moses is like no no
don't do that God you know like turn
away from your anger and your Fierce
wrath so so the emotions I believe God
designed us to to feel and have and
they're appropriate in a certain in
certain circumstances and you know so
definitely don't just you know I love
that I know but listen emotions have to
be felt they have to they're indicators
of our thoughts and if we are in a habit
of numbing them and cutting them off
then we won't know what's really going
on inside but they let us know they're
not to be you know um the the Kings or
the governors but they are indicators to
helpless yeah yeah I hope you guys were
blessed and I know you're going to want
to tune in and see the next show that
she's gonna come on and do
um this has been valuable information I
hope that somebody out there listening
today that maybe swallowing in their own
depression and cannot even know where to
begin I hope and pray that this was just
a just a little spark of inspiration a
little piece of Hope for you if you are
a parent and maybe this is giving you
the inspiration or the tools to start
checking in with your children
um you know build that communication
open that door
um if you felt like this or you you want
to be a co-worker that is you know like
like a safe place for you to run around
and and make your other co-workers be
like their their valued and loved
um I hope that this was inspiring for
you so thank you Mia and if you want
we'll put a link to uh her website you
have a website oh absolutely yes all
right where can people get a hold of you
so you can reach us at
payingunwaisted.org
painunwaisted.org go on there book a
call we'd love to talk to you we'd love
to speak to you um if you are feeling
suicidal we do want you to reach out to
988 okay that is a helpline that can
help you right away but if you're
interested in our services or connecting
with us being trained pain on wasted.org
thank you thank you guys for tuning in
and we hope and pray that you were
blessed we'll see you next week and
please share this video with somebody
that you may feel benefit will benefit
from this or just is is it's just great
information for a loved one so that they
may be aware for this topic as well we
thank you and love you God bless
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]